[Music]
trial and error is submitted by see you
tomato that's an old joke I imagine a
tomato talking that's pretty funny my
mind don't go this is how dwelling on
your failures could be the key to your
success what how Welling well I could
kind of see that it's cuz like you're so
obsessive that you want to change it and
you work at it you don't want to repeat
that same mistakes you constantly think
about overall this is another way of
saying learning from your mistakes the
wrong verbage that you know yeah well
like dwelling is not the correct
reflecting and learning from it yeah oh
you've got in it like you haven't came
with the solution you're marinating in
it that's wrong verbage see this yeah
well what's what's the definition of
dwelling is it when you're paralyzed and
you're just moping around and you're not
doing anything about it or dwelling is
someone who can't get over it because
dwelling means you haven't gotten over
right because that's that's how I saw
that word in this context is someone
who's dwelling over a topic they can't
get over it and they're obsessive about
never going through it I think it's just
like how it's used in our terms is not
the way like that though well how it's
going to be said in my personal opinion
we haven't heard it yet but I don't hear
somebody saying like yeah I dwell on my
failures yeah maybe if they're reminded
the user they're failures to remind them
and then that's how they become
successful like acknowledge it and then
learn from it well they never again
instead of it keeping up keeping you up
every night for the rest of your life
yeah cuz how do you sleep and then wake
up and then get your [ __ ] done to like
make sure it doesn't happen again
yeah you need a really strong coffee pod
oh you guys that's what what dwelling is
defined as it's how players live the
house it's either to live in or a
specified place or the other one is
think speak or write at length about a
particular subject especially one that
is a source of unhappiness anxiety or
dissatisfaction oh it's an active thing
to write or speak about right because
I'd well yeah I thought it was like
stinking yeah
that's not the conversational definition
that we have yeah think speak I think
was the first time I'm just dueling
about it been Annette I know she did
something you saw our video thick hello
yeah so this new research suggests that
people who embrace their failures and
the negative feelings that come with it
are more likely to appear in the future
embracing like to see yeah it makes
sense
yeah and that's because they don't
protect their ego by thinking that they
did their best and instead they learn
from their mistakes yeah it's good yeah
what makes sense why does David look
like Trump right now sleeping sleeping
like it's your own hair
it's going to be huge hands you know
huge from one side the lower jaw huge he
has always had to study those it's to
bed this he's like I like the accordion
thing he's they're doing with you guys
think about your failures and I don't
know yours I like to learn from them
yeah I don't like to sit there like you
know recently Casey tonight we had a
discussion where I realized growing up a
lot of my teachers like they weren't
afraid to make kids feel stupid for
asking questions so I grew up in an
environment where it's like I'm scared
to ask the question oh yeah yeah that's
how my family was too if you asked a
dumb question like you're so [ __ ]
stupid then they smack you so then I
never want to ask yeah yeah no I I feel
like that made me afraid of failure like
seeking information because I just
didn't want to look at someone stupid
that for sure was something that
affected me well see that's like
something that I felt too but then I I
got over that because like what that
leads into is a lot of people just
trying to say things to be included yeah
I mean so I [ __ ] that now now I'm just
unapologetically myself so whether
people whatever you think about me is
whatever you think but I'm gonna say how
I feel and how it is because before when
you were sit around and not ask
questions you're just gonna be dumb for
the rest of your life or you pretend
like you know what other people are
talking about and you
Dunning yeah so that's like the opposite
of what I did because my dad used to
always beat it and like I remember when
I was a kid I used to be so nervous I
couldn't even order food at a fast food
Oh
so I was just scared then my dad just
beat my ass
he goes you gotta learn how to do this
so I got over that [ __ ] and maybe that's
why I don't agree with the whole
dwelling thing because it's just like I
recognized it in the name you want well
in this context you know I think they're
not using dwell yeah yeah yeah
so they they should use it as embracing
your failures but never forgetting and
using that negative moment as good
motivation to change your obsessive yeah
so yeah what is the word maybe obsessing
is a better Mike Howard dwelling on the
usage of the word yeah
I could I could really understand it
though because I think I'm really
obsessive and I remember as a kid if I
didn't get the answer I just wouldn't
stop thinking about it yeah so I had to
get the answers so I don't care how many
times I can beat or astok teacher or
whatever yeah I just keep asking I think
I'm like that now as an adult like now
that's why I constantly ask questions I
don't care that I sound stupid asking
them because I just I'm like you know
what I learned from my childhood I want
to be like that anymore I want to I want
to learn things I don't want to avoid
the worst people are the ones were like
like I say Joe what's a t-shirt what do
you do with it and they're like you
don't know what it is oh we yeah yeah we
do that's Isaac sometimes I'm thinking
and then I cut them off I'm like well
[ __ ] tell me the last four sentences
you said Ben teach no one [ __ ] exactly
say it Ben and then that's when he
realized oh [ __ ] sorry there's a better
road to take in those situations yeah
for us it's like because we see Isaac
and we're like oh nine years old like at
that time we did this I'd already forget
that you don't first
and I was like oh he never came across
say I don't I can't come up with an
example of forgetting my here and have
our experiences and then we're coming to
him like what again you didn't learn
that you didn't do that but once I
recognize I'm like oh [ __ ] we got to
stop it's a certain school that makes
people really scared to ask questions
you know about drugs you know what a key
bunker that's true when someone's too
innocent they don't know enough about
drugs yeah it's like look why should
they know I hate it's like ridiculous
[ __ ] I know a guy who's a history major
right I ask them something I didn't
remember like something if I could learn
like their degree like [ __ ]
Mesopotamia or something you don't know
that Mesopotamia oh my god everyone
learned that in third grade how can you
not like shut the [ __ ] up and just tell
me you're wasting more time so of course
I know I had friends but there are
certain times though were like it's
surprising I met a guy that's been
living in LA the whole like his whole
life and he's only he's been to Santa
Monica once so like stuff like that is
like yeah we're like you know you've
been in LA all your life and you and you
never ate a taco or something I'm like
wow these are from Texas too you grew up
in LA but you're you're you're
intelligent it's more of an experience
thing like I'm so surprised oh yeah we
all we do that to Bart a lot yeah cuz
he's you know all the movies that we
watch like Disney movies or whatever
it's like I can't believe you never
watched [ __ ] Pinocchio or some [ __ ]
challenging is [ __ ] intelligent yeah
that's not like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
never watch puddin
the two holes that was challenging that
was pretty crazy there's also like that
I think is because of the obscurity that
makes is so infuriating like history no
it doesn't hurt my feelings
veena weird words can someone explain to
be really quick where Cooney came from
CUNY CUNY say it right ml come on
shootin what just like you're being cute
like a cutie or whatever and then you
just swap out some words it's very
simple there's no really crazy okay baby
okay there's a really funny
Geena comment where she goes I like how
it comes today I love this blanket that
she watches later when he's always like
a [ __ ] hater so much as he's either
awake or asleep that's all he is right I
like awake asleep pooping yeah boy the
poop face is real hmm
do you guys have any failures that
you're like you'll always remember or
some do you consider a failure that my
whole life is a complete failure
you always keep at the forefront of your
mind I don't ever get regret or regret
of some sort yeah I think like trusting
the wrong people but that's what taught
you about people that CFS you I feel
like every negative or stress or
whatever you go through you can kind of
look back and say oh [ __ ] I learn
something from it and now I'm better for
it but yeah if you just get stabbed out
of nowhere it's like
what I learned from that like a [ __ ]
runs away I'm like I didn't
what the [ __ ] don't walk by yourself in
a [ __ ] vest in a leather jacket just
walks around with phone books taped
around a stomach I'm a better person for
this guy you met him the first time
what Hey yeah didn't you have something
like in his stomach
Oh at the San Diego Festival yeah yeah
yeah it was that defended you had like
some [ __ ] it was that and also you
scream yeah I was like a program you had
it like yeah I forgot what the joke was
done I can't remember we have to look at
her old JK [ __ ] videos I think the
first time you guys met uh he was
tripping out on you cuz one you were
super loud and you were just speaking at
the movie like we can't hear anything
and then you've had like the the program
of all the movies and [ __ ] talk to him
into your like pants yeah and underneath
your shirt and he was like that's a
[ __ ] prison shirt yeah you did some
weird [ __ ] back in the day oh you're my
favorite young old man these are cool I
don't even remember half this much I
feel like you're gonna be not even like
when you're old but like in a week or so
you're gonna have one of those telephone
clips on your waist but I really do like
failing though that's like my [ __ ]
that's like my skill dude like failing
is actually pretty cool because it helps
you feel alive it does actually when you
get constant affirmation what you do
this is why sometimes I feel like in
this world everybody gets a confirmation
or affirmation from doing nothing so
sometimes it's good to fail because it
shows you where you're at and you'll
have room to grow my first audition this
year didn't [ __ ] terrible this is
what I did like I walked in and I'm so I
thought that this role that I read was
the comedy it was for a comedic role it
was like some CSI murder [ __ ] and then
when I saw I'm on I'm getting taped
right and she says the first flight and
it's super serious I was like I [ __ ]
up I just like I did she goes that was
probably one of the most interesting
reads I was like cool I walked outside I
went to my car I need a seat back
so I was mortified that's later the car
like you that's a terrible feeling I
just imagine she's Federline he's like
yeah her face was cut up in [ __ ]
mortal and I just kind of took that but
at the same time it felt awesome because
I'm so bad it shows I have so much more
room to grow so it doesn't mean that I
must stay there that means like hey get
your [ __ ] ass in gear
competitions high get your ass up there
too so that was kind of cool and that
feeling is kind of like a chase all the
time except for like working out other
than that is hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discussed just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video click right up hey
[Music]